pour en parler nous sommes avec ardavan
amir-aslani avocat et spécialiste du
moyen orient bonjour merci d'être avec
nous ce matin alors pourquoi ce plan il
est temps contesté finalement parce que
il est loin c'est vrai de faire
l'unanimité on l'a vu avec les
différentes manifestations à ramallah en
tunisie ce plan se situe entre
directement dans la volonté de
l'administration trappe d'accorder toute
sorte concession au pouvoir et sereine
rappelons que trump avait décidé malgré
70 ans nos politiques constantes des
états unis de transférer la base à des
etats-unis à jérusalem de reconnaître
jérusalem comme la capitale israélienne
de reconnaître l'annexion du golan par
israël et jared kushner qui est un des
proches en fait de netanyahu avec ce
plan là ne fait que consacrer cette
volonté américaine de privilégier
l'intérêt d'israël par vos palais
quand vous regardez ce plan que ce que
vous y constaterez qu aucun des
attributs de la souveraineté d'un état
ne sont présents vous voyez que les
palestiniens n'auront pas le contrôle de
leur espace aérien ne rompt pas le
contrôle si vous voulez de leurs
frontières
leur pays va être morcelé a que 2 200
colonies israéliennes qui vont être
acquitté et annexé par israël
la vallée du jourdain sera également
totalement excès les ressources de l'eau
vont de contrôle paradis serait un peu
de 80% mais pas les siennes ne rompt pas
d'affaires étrangères a mal de manière
devant le souverain il s'agit d'un plan
qui est en fait une plaisanterie
est-ce qu'il peut être appliqué ce plan
les palestiens déso contraire leur
demande était régulièrement répété et le
droit au retour la souveraineté absolue
le la en l'occurrence ils n'ont même pas
si vous voulez d'armé pour assurer le
contrôle
en terme de leur pays le plan n'a pas
été acceptée palestiniens ça a été
immédiatement rejetée par à la première
heure d'air par l'ensemble des pays au
monde
l'idée derrière jugée sensée v2 d'offrir
à l'autorité palestinienne 50 milliards
$
comme si 50 milliards $ était largement
suffisant pour bradley sur économique de
pas le sien volée à la maîtrise de l'eau
50 milliards de dollars parce qu'il ya
un volet aussi économique dans ce plan
c'est l'un des aspects intéressants
quand même dieu de ce plan de donald
trump les palestiniens inspiré à avoir
un état indépendant
un effet s'ouvre on leur propose rien
une sorte de bantoustans comme vous
regardez bien les 50 milliards vont
servir à quoi
ils n'ont même pas si vous voulez
suffisamment de ressources d'eau pour
pratiquer l'agriculture ont franchement
c'est quelque chose qui n'a aucune
chance d'aboutir vers le plan avant même
son annonce mytouch c'est qu'il faut
constater ici que malgré tout mahmoud
abbas maintient le dialogue dans les
premières heures de l'annoncé a déclaré
qu'il avait arrêté toute forme de
coopération avec des israéliens mais
s'est ravisé et il a décidé en tout cas
au match aller à la parade sur les
questions sécuritaires
puisque vous parlez de mahmoud abbas
est-ce que ce plan finalement il a quand
même l'avantagé de réunir autour d'une
même table le fatah de mahmoud abbas et
le hamas
depuis l'échec des accords d'oslo il n'y
a plus de dialogue en pré-séance raid
c'est un voile a au moins le mérite de
mettre de nouveau la question serait
6ème sur la table et de permettre
peut-être un forum pour les discussions
à venir mais c'est un plan qui ne
saurait s'appliquer en état et un
rapprochement interpalestinien aussi
entre les deux factions politiques du
hamas à gaza a racheté ce plan là au
même titre que le fatah à hans et
jordanie ça n'a pas fait pour les
rapprocher
eni aujourd'hui dans un bloc de refus
canton ce plan un plan de paix
israélo-palestinien aujourd'hui qui
pourrait fonctionner quelles en seraient
les conditions qu'est ce qui manque
aujourd'hui au plan américain qui est
comme beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup lui
reprochent justement d'être pro
palestiniens le plan américaine n'est
pas le tout problème et non pro
israéliens pendant ce plan est
totalement pro israélien suez les
israéliens avaient un certain nombre de
manques la totalité de ceux demande là
ont été actés accepté après par les airs
avec aucune demande de benest aucune
sans même si vous voulez est leur donner
ce qu'ils leur revendication historique
c'est-à-dire une part de jérusalem est
en fait quand on parle de jérusalem est
dans le plan de de paix de jacques
hochner on parle de la banlieue éloignée
de jérusalem qui est effectivement à
l'est jérusalem c'est pas du tout à
jérusalem où en fait quand vous voulez
aboutir à un accord qui se bat nature à
obtenir l'adhésion de la partie encore
faut-il pour partie abouti à un
compromis
il n'y a aucune semble compromis ce
plan-là acte exclusivement de la posture
ali et leïla question jérusalem aussi
dans ce plan qui pose problème en tout
cas côté palestinien absolument comme je
l'aï appelé les israéliens et blessé un
systématiquement revendiquent la partie
jérusalem est y compris le mont du
temple comme leur capitale souveraine
mais cette demande a été totalement
rachetées et on le voit aujourd'hui tous
les pays arabes le bal m'en a parlé deux
ou trois qui étaient présents qui qu'ils
sont unis si j'ose dire avec des états
unis dans l'arène de l'iran on peut tous
les pays arabes l'ont rejeté la ligue
arabe qui s'est réuni immédiatement
derrière
dans son ensemble large desquelles je le
vois pas quelles sont les chances de ce
plan en fait c'est encore une fois une
nouvelle opportunité perdue
merci beaucoup ardavan amir-aslani je
rappelle que cet avocat et spécialiste
du moyen orient merci à vous merci à
vous